so good morning welcome to
GRP see on Donna core so about me my
name is James Newton King I'm a
developer on the asp.net team since the
beginning of this year I've been looking
at G RPC and how we can improve the GI
PC experience on net core and I'm happy
to say everything I'm going to show you
today is available now at launch worth
Donnie core 3 o last month so let's just
start by getting an understanding of who
who feels comfortable about
understanding what gr PC is if you have
you've got a good idea about what G RPC
is and what it's used for
put your hands up so it's maybe a third
of people maybe half who is using gr PC
whether it's Annette or any other
platform Java C++ go so it's maybe half
a dozen hints so let's let's start off
by talking about what exactly she RPC is
so it's a remote procedure call
framework as far as I can tell it's
probably got the largest mindshare out
of remote procedure called frameworks
the community the overall developer
community is really coalescing around it
it was originally created by Google but
is now run by the cloud native computing
foundation and the G&G RPC doesn't stand
for Google it's a recursive acronym that
stands for G RPC remote procedure calls
so GRP see it's not new it was has
actually been around since 2015 but it
is built with modern technologies so G
RPC is really the union of two cool
technologies is HCB - which acts as its
underlying protocol and then there's
protobuf okay a protocol buffers I'll
call it protobuf throughout the rest of
us talk and it acts as like a contract
language and also the serialization
format GBC has designed for modern
applications its high-performance it
uses a binary protocol and H should be
too and also proto buffers binary
creates very small messages very fast
messages it's quite easy to create real
time services who's in charge
and GBC is platform independent so it's
now supported and don't it call well but
it's also supported and knowed Java Ruby
C++ Python go rust pretty much anything
you can think of gr PC support certain
so let's talk a bit about what proto
buffers so protobuf actually serves a
number of purposes and gr pc the first
purpose as it serves as an interface
definition language it's a language
independent way of defining messages
that your services are going to send and
receive and that proto file is then
shared between applications so your
contract needs to be known both about on
the server and on the client so here we
can see a couple of messages and you'll
notice that against each field so topic
ID details we're specifying a number
when protobuf sends a message it doesn't
send the entire message name like it's
not a cell prescriptive format you need
to have a contract on both sides
protobuf also acts as the definition of
the service model so here we have a
topic service and then a method on that
service call subscribe you can think of
a t RPC service like a controller and a
method like in action and in protobuf is
the wire format so that's the actual
serialization and we'll take those
messages that are defined and c-sharp
dotnet and we'll turn it into this
binary format so it's small and fast and
then it will get sent across HTTP 2 to
the client and because this is an open
standard you get the benefits of a
binary format and that it's very fast
but also because it's standards-based as
cross-platform like it's not a donut
only thing which you can't communicate
with other services you get the best of
both worlds it's also important to note
that because it's binary is not human
readable you need to have both tools to
understand the binary unless you're
amazing at reading binary or and you
also need to have the contract because
it's not a self descriptor
of mystery and format let's talk a bit
about the conceptual differences between
remote procedure calls and HT PAP is
Mecca main rest it could mean pretty
much anything which has cent worth HCP
plus Jason today so G RPC it's an
opinionated contract first technology if
we compare that to HTTP API is there
more about the content that's what you
think about first you want to craft your
JSON to look the way you want it to look
you want to create user friendly URLs
which people can look at and build up
and they can read and understand what's
going on
gee RPC it's a lot more opinionated and
that that's the contract which matters
more than what gets into cross the wire
and with char pcs that contract that's
designed for humans
you saw it a bit earlier it's very easy
to read and understand you can type it
out yourself and modify it and you can
give it to someone else and they can
look at what's going on if we compare
that with HG PAP is the content is
designed for humans so you're able to
look at a rest call and you can see that
that URL is for product number five and
here is the JSON of what you want to
have set against their products you've
got first-name equals John lastname
equals Smith here is his age you can
read and understand that worth protobuf
the with GBC like the opposite is true
you can't read the message but also with
ACP API is if you're using a contract
like technology like swagger or open API
those contracts like not very user
friendly you not able to easily read
them or create them without tools you
probably want to use a tool like like a
swagger generation tool to generate that
file rather than writing it yourself so
I think the overall message worth remote
procedure calls as the the idea behind
them is to hide the complexity of remote
hang you should be able to invoke
methods and net and have them run on a
completely different server with
having to worry about the underlying
mechanism and what's getting sent
meanwhile HCP api's generally if you
want to invoke them you're probably
creating an HTTP client you're building
up a URL you're serializing some JSON
you're seeing that into the body then
you're sending it off okay so let's look
at a demo of using G RPC so in Visual
Studio 2015 we have a new template which
came with dotnet core 3 so it's AG RPC
service so we just type in char PC
service it comes up click Next click
create wait a few seconds click create
again so this is a basic hello world
application it has a single greeter
service and we can send hello name to
there and reply with hello and that name
so let's look at about at what was
created so we have our G RPC service
that doesn't work very well so we have
our G RPC service over here and we've
got the typical things you would see
with a G's an ASP Donaire core
application we've got to start up we've
got a program CS we've got some settings
we've got a couple of extra directories
so first one is this proto's directory
none of that we have greet proto open
that up so this is that contract I
talked about here you can see we've got
our greeter service we've got to say
hello
that takes a hello request which we can
see down here and we've got hello reply
which take returns message so that's the
name we're going to pass in and the
message we're going to return and then n
services we've got a greatest service so
this is an implementation of that
greeter contract so we've got say hello
I've got a hello request we've got a
server call context think of a server
call context like an HTTP context so it
really just gives you a bunch of
contextual information about the call
which is going on and then we're
returning a task of hallo reply because
this is just a synchronous method we're
saying to us not from result when we're
giving it a response so something which
pops out right here is these are the
only files we have in our application
where is greater bass coming from where
is hello requests coming from where is
hello reply so cogeneration is at the
core of G RPC by using this proto file
and tooling we're able to generate
c-sharp implementations of these types
so not just the request and reply but
also Vaska reader base and if we
navigate to greet a base we can see
we've got some generated code a bit
bigger sure
so this is our generated code although
it's generated code I wouldn't be too
afraid of it like I think there's bad
generated code which you need to worry
about like you need to manually update
some hangman you need to do some step
and then it gets checked under source
control when it gets out of date between
every one I would define this as good
generated code there's this generated
code you don't even need to think about
there is logic built into msbuild
that will automatically at compile time
regenerate that as soon as you make any
changes to your proto file so another
thing to notice about this is we've got
dependency injection hooked up so we are
integrating into asp.net core you can
use dependency injection you can use
logging you can use a asp.net core orth
indication you can use middleware all
that good stuff and if we look at our
startup file we can see we've got
configure services
we're just saying add G RPC and then
down and endpoints in point routing
we've just got mapped G RPC service and
we've got our implementation okay so
let's run this and see what happens
okay so we've launched our app on
localhost 5001 so we can browse to that
and we got this message what does this
say
communication with qi RPC endpoints must
be made through a gr PC client so G RPC
it's not like rest where you can just
browse to a URL and because you're doing
a get will just return you some data and
you can easily debug like that jarppi
see you really need to have a client so
we will create a compliant right now and
Donette so i will add a console
application regular Donette core console
application and I foolishly installed
the latest preview so I need to update
some stuff so it will work I'll just
build this okay so there are a couple of
ways I could add the client here I could
add some new get packages I mean I could
add a reference to vet proto file the
way the proto fire was referenced in our
project file and I agree to service as
is this protobuf element so this is us
telling the project and then the
compiler itself here is our proto file
and we want to generate it at least here
on the server we want server generation
which means we want to generate a server
space class Rev and generate a concrete
client so we could add those NuGet
packages an alternative way is an visual
CEO we have aired connected service so
if anyone's son W see if this might look
a little familiar so you can come into
service references and say add new G RPC
reference we're going to browse on disk
to our proto file greet proto okay okay
so we're gonna there's visual Co it's
going to add some new get packages and
it's going to add that proto file and
we're done so
nothing like unlike WCF when you add a
service reference like we're not calling
off to a server and getting a soap
request and then generating some code
then at that point all we're doing is in
the client we're adding some more stuff
to the project file so we've got some
package references and then our proto
file note our proto file now C is client
because we're on the client now let's
talk about these packages so Google
protobuf misses the serialization
runtime serialization a protobuf GBC net
client this is the client implementation
of T RPC and then she RPC tools this is
the runtime tooling and code generation
okay let's write some code to call our
service so the first thing we'll do is
we'll create a channel so you can think
of channel is like a representation of
our connection to the G RPC server and
all we do is we'll type in the address
of our server which was 5001 done now we
need to create a client using that
channel and if all has gone to plan
we can see greeter so greeter has shown
up so that wasn't a type we've ever
created this isn't a type that we're
getting by referencing the server dll's
this has been coaching rated within the
console application so we say greeter
greet client and then we give it the
channel and that's it okay now we want
to make some calls so on client we've
got a couple of couple of methods so
we've got say hello might be a little
small for some people but we've got say
hello and we have say hello async these
both call the same service are the same
method just the difference is one's
blocking one is asynchronous it's you
see asynchronous because blocking is bad
so we've got our hello request this is
pretty much the exact same types that
the server has taken
give it a name say hello to in DC Sydney
get the response because it's a sink
we'll wait it and because we wait it we
need to make this a sink
ok so we've now made I call let's write
out their response
done okay so theoretically we should be
finished so let's launch these two so
this is the server
this is the client so yes I server
successfully started up and fingers
crossed that broke yeah
okay let's actually try compiling things
I did just update the latest Visual
Studio preview which was a bad move a
rookie a rookie mistake okay so that's a
theater maybe cogeneration just got a
little a little funky
okay there we go so that successfully
called the client to the server so we
can see I'm a client we got our response
and on the server asp.net has written
out some output so we can see our
request has come in so we've got
requests starting HTTP to post I mean
has come into this URL so localhost 5001
then greet service URL greet is the
package that the G RPC services in
greeter is the service name and then say
hello was the method name and that's
just all there is to basic - yeah PC
it's very very easy to setup it's very
fast and efficient and product
productive I think but like unlike a
technology like WCF you're not worrying
about all these different knobs and
dials for configuration G RPC in its
default status let's just do protobuf
that's your choice and let's just do
HTTP - and then you just go and use use
G RPC so the question was about the
routes so G RPC is very convention based
so the routes are are required suppose
that is the format like you can modify
that by changing the package name or the
service name of a method name but those
three things combined that what that is
what builds up the route and that's a
strict requirement and for G RPC
specification you know you don't care
and if you do care then maybe Jia PC
might not be the right technology for
you like you might be better off doing
something like a QP API is using using
NB C so let's go a bit deeper on what
we've created and Donnie core three four
G RPC so like I said before Jia BC isn't
new g RPC isn't new on Donette either so
we already had this technology this new
get package called G RPC course so
that's already came from a cloud native
computing foundation this has been
around since 2015 and it's
been doing a great job there are a
couple of issues with it so this
implementation it's kind of a thunder
net wrapper around a native
implementation so the server and client
and also the hup-two library they're
implemented and native see rather than
c-sharp that has some downsides around
performance because you've got the
overhead of donít interrupt and also the
native code would be faster just to do
it all on one technology and also all
those native binaries they're quite
large because it's multiplied by all the
different target service package has
this is a very big package it's a big
boy it's about 50 megabytes in size
it's what have we introduced some
dhaniya core threes so we've got GI PC
asp net core so that's our server
implementation it sits on top of Kestrel
and it uses Kestrel for its HTTP Susac
and it integrates with asp.net core so
like I said dependency injection routing
or not routing but it uses that for
out'n configuration authentication
authorization all of that stuff you can
just reuse with a speed net core and you
can use it side by side with other
technologies so you can have a MVC app
alongside of a ER PC app maybe on the
same port may be on different different
ports our client is G RBC doneto client
it's also a fully Donette implementation
and it uses HTTP 2 via HP client and
because it uses HTTP client you can use
existing HTTP client technologies like
delegating handlers acts almost as like
outgoing middleware for your G RPC calls
now what we've done is we've taken the
common API of a PC core and we've split
it off into its own package so what
api's are these these are things like
that server call context
the base type of a channel the base type
for the client mr. metadata API sand
there's some authorization api's this is
all good stuff so one of our goals of
our new implementation is to be
compatible with qi RPC core and we've
achieved that by splitting it off into
its own package and then having it
reference by all our implementations so
what does that mean it means if you're
in da near call and you can just use a
PC core you can use these new GC
implementations and you don't really
need to worry about G RPC core or its
native implementation but if you are
using qi RPC core today and you want to
move to these new implementations
they're very compatible like pretty much
all the changes you'll need to make will
be in the application startup code on
the server and how you go about creating
that channel on the client so let's talk
about why you might want to use G RPC so
I think one of the keep key features as
a performance so the size of G RPC
request should pretty much always be
smaller than an equivalent HTP request
using JSON and that's done via HTTP 2 so
it's a binary protocol it uses binary
framing and also it has header
compression so all the plain text ACP
headers which gets sent today worth 1
point 1 and heb - those can be
compressed and to a much smaller size
and then there's the protobuf messages
so bro protobuf it's a binary format and
it's like I said before it's not self
descriptive so you don't have a lot of
repeating information getting sent like
property names aren't getting sent with
every request that information is
recorded once in the contract and then
by being able to share of a contract you
don't need to repeat that all the time
so let's imagine some JSON with some
equivalent protobuf so we've got some
Jason on the Left we've got an
equivalent protobuf contract on the
right
but these look about the same size but
the contract isn't what's getting sent
what's getting sent there's some very
small and efficient binary so this is a
comparison that someone I'm a
communities of Jason verse some
equivalent protobuf and protobuf is
between a quarter and a third the size
of Jason which is a significant saving
so another way
jiya BC gets good performance is via
HTTP to Modi flex zone so HTTP 1.1 you
tend to have a single TCP connection and
a limited number of requests can go
across at at the same time and even when
you do have multiple requests again
through an HB through a TCP connection
you can get into a situation where one
request box another so if one request is
particularly slow it will hold up all
the requests behind it and they can't
complete until it completes so this is
called head-of-line blocking and HTTP 2
for the most part solves it so I've got
a little Asterix there it doesn't
completely solve every single use case
and makes it considerably better but
HTTP 3 is a perspective technology which
may completely solve head of line
blocking so to give an example of hgp
1.1 versus - oh this is an image split
up into 100 small images and you can see
with 1.1 it takes a while to download
that's because only so many requests can
be can be made at once well - OH
pretty much the client in this case as a
browser can just request every single
one mentor once Mayall quickly download
so cogeneration cogeneration is really
at the core of qi RPC and their
cogeneration is driven by the protobuf
and face definition language services
this language neutral contract format
which you can easily read edit exchange
with other people so we start off with
this contract file in this case we've
got a request and we've got an event in
this case this is a streaming call I'll
talk about streaming pretty soon and
what we do at least and our net is we
reference some new get packages so we
talked about Google Doc protobuf that's
the runtime serialization technology
we've got your PC tools so that's the
tool length that will recognize the
protobuf file and your project and do
the cogeneration and then we have the
asp net core server so that's the server
implementation and then we have this
protobuf reference and that's
referencing the protobuf file on disk
and then what type of cogeneration you
want so you can say server you can say
client F for some reason you want to
both call and receive in the same
project you can say both as well so the
code which is generated if you're on the
server this is the server space class by
default it will have virtual methods on
it and those virtual methods will just
throw a not implemented error so if
someone if you had a proto file and you
only wanted to implement one out of
multiple services you could do that and
then if someone tries to call other
services it will just throw a not
implemented error back to the client and
then this is the strongly typed G RPC
client so this will take the request and
it will return a streaming object this
is strongly typed it will also take a
client channel based on the constructor
so that represents the connection a
channel can be used with multiple
clients so you can create one
channel and then you can create a topics
client and agree to client all of those
can use a single channel so it's
important to note that the meta data
which I haven't shown in these code
examples there's also code generated so
that metadata is information about the
calls you can think of that as like
instructions about how to serialize and
deserialize instructions about the URL
router needs to go and some other other
metadata so another key feature Jia BC
is supported and every language so this
isn't a thing which marks off is made up
this is an open standard which we are
contributing to so pretty much any
implementation any modern language in
common use today has CIBC library and
all of these G RPC libraries are
interoperable with one another so there
is a integration suite and some Interop
tests and every client and server
including ours will strive to pass all
of those and then those are continuously
tested so there's a integration test
server which is run by the CN CF and as
requests well as updates happen to
clients and servers will continuously
run every client against every server
every possible permutation which as you
can imagine quickly ends up to thousands
and thousands of tests and that's done
pretty much every chicken so G RPC is
highly compatible and it's usable pretty
much everywhere so streaming I think
streaming is one of the probably the
most interesting features of G RPC so
ACB - has excellent streaming support
and Qi RPC uses that streaming support
to enable string of messages so there
are actually a number of different kinds
of Qi RPC methods we've kind of already
seen a couple of them so we've got unary
methods unary method is like what you
would have in rest you've got a single
request and a single response
it's about greater service I showed you
before that had a sing
Griet requests and it had a single greet
reply we've got service streaming so
server streaming that's initiated by the
client sending request then the server
returning a stream of updates so you
could imagine with a GRDC call you could
subscribe to weather updates so you
could come across to a server you could
say I'm a request here is my location
and then the server over like pretty an
arbitrary long time can just stream down
request so with one call you can avoid
polling and all that kind of thing you
can do it efficiently and quickly this
client streaming which as you can
imagine is pretty much the opposite so
an example of this might be you want to
upload a lot of data so maybe you stream
data up to a server and then when you're
complete so the client will indicate to
the server hey I'm done streaming the
server can then do some work and then it
can return a response and bi-directional
streaming is pretty much what you would
expect streaming in both directions an
example of this might be a chat room so
you can say any messages you're typing
will get sent to the server and their
own individual char PC messages and then
all the other messages on the server can
get streamed back down to you so I'll do
a demo of streaming very soon but before
that let's go a bit deeper on how
exactly G RPC works on the wire so
imagine HTTP 1.1 we've got a text
request which starts off with some ticks
base headers so we've got posts which is
a method we've got a URL blah blah blah
we've also got the request body so this
can be any content in this case is just
some awesome text it's hello world and
JSON how does that map to HTTP 2 so they
should be - it's a binary protocol and
it's built around the idea of framing so
we've got a headers frame as you can
imagine the headers go into the headers
frame
and then we've got a data frame so the
content the body goes into the data
let's look at a G RPC request
now although Jia PC you don't get
control over what gets sent like you
don't get control over the URL and
pretty much every requests will always
be a post and it's an RPC technology
like WCF unlike w CF g RPC doesn't
completely ignore the fact that it's
living in an HTTP 2 environment it's not
like WCF where you have a single
endpoint and you're posting an envelope
of xml to the server and then the
server's unwrapping their job easier
still uses hqb to HQ p concepts so if we
want to send additional metadata with
our request we can send those as headers
so in this case you can see we're doing
a post to that URL so we've got our
greet which is a service named greeter
which is we've got greet which is the
package name greed of a service name and
say hello which is Method and then we've
got one world
so again headers under the head of
Supreme One world and to the data frame
there's only the one because the
property name isn't sent because as a
self describing format protobuf and
obviously like I'm a real world this
would be binary I'm just giving you a
textual representation of what it would
look like it's like a responses so this
is an HP one response as you expect with
those stairs code was a message again
we've got hitters under headers frame
their body and to the data frame so this
is the G RPC response so this is where
it starts diverging at all from what you
would expect
so the GI BC response headers they go
into a hitter's frame the body the
content goes into a data frame but
what's this Qi RPC status so I don't i
if one of it one of the issues with one
point one is once you send through
request headers there's no additional
ways to easily see in it additional
metadata like if you've ever want to
send
like how long did the server request
take and send that as a header you
haven't been able to do that at one
point one because the headers have
already been sent and you can't easily
add that to the body like you can like
maybe encode the body in such a way that
you can add metadata at the end but it
is an automatic so what a CB 2 has as it
has just another headers frame so this
is known as trailing headers also known
as trailers and with HTTP 2 you can
really think of the request and a
response not as a single request like
you would worth one point one where you
have headers and a body and you send
that and then you get a response you can
think of a CB 2 as a stream from the
client to the server of frames these can
be multiple headers frames multiple data
frames and then the opposite coming back
so in this case because it's a unary
request we've got one here Doe one data
I mean another header to say that it's
exceeded so the question you might ask
is why do we need two successes because
we've already got 200 okay that's sent
with the headers why do we need a second
status and we need it because of
streaming so like you can have multiple
header frames you can have multiple data
frames so if we were streaming from the
server to the client we can just send
hello world and one data frame maybe we
need to do some more processing we wait
a couple of seconds then we send another
reply and another data frame and another
one and then that last hit a frame
that's giving the overall status of our
call because those headers they were
sent to the client in the very first
message we need to send a status at the
very end to say hey this overall
streaming had succeeded okay so let's go
and extend our basic hello greeter to do
some streaming so if this is our unary
call it takes one request one reply
let's do some service streaming
so they say say hello streaming we take
one request and to make it streaming we
just add stream that's all you do that's
it
now if we wanted to do bi-directional
streaming we just said stream over here
and if we wanted to do client streaming
we get rid of this one let's just leave
it at service streaming save that now we
need to implement it on the server
now if cogeneration has done its job
we've got hello stream in say hello
stream in so there's a couple of
differences here they're still taking a
hello request but there's no more
message getting returned with the task
and also we've got this new parameter
called service streamwriter hello reply
so the stream Rider is how we return the
messages from the server
so first let's make it a sync so
response stream has write async this is
the method we'll be using to return
messages say hello reply message
actually let's this had a for loop so 10
times
or wait this
say hello get that request get the name
from it and so we can see what's going
on we'll get the index and that looks
like it so that's it so that's how you
do service streaming on the server all
you're doing is you've got your messages
you've got your response stream you just
write two response stream and you're
done now on the client now usually if
you've got two different proto files you
need to make the change in both when we
reference this Greek proto file we just
added a link to it so it's actually
referencing the same location although
sometimes code generation doesn't
automatically run and other projects
when the linker updates oops I need to
stop these guys let's try that again
okay so that built it's coming out are
you nor equal so client let's go say
hello streaming we need to give it a
request
and because we're returning multiple
responses we're no longer like we can no
longer just or wait like we did before
to get a response now server streaming
calls and in fact all streaming calls
will just return an object which will
represent the overall call a man on that
call we have a response stream so a
spawn stream is what we'll use to get
the messages coming from the server back
to the client and read them so we've got
some methods on this so we can say move
next and we can wait there and then we
can access it from current that's that's
usable but what we've done and a speed
on in core as we've added an async
iterative method called read all async
and using that we can use a fancy new
asynchronous for each
console.writeline and we'll just write
out our message and I think we're done
so let's start our server again
let's start our client and let's see
what happens okay a worked I think it
worked really quickly and that's because
ERP C is really fast and we didn't add a
delay so let's add a delay over here so
we can see what's going on a bit better
let's wait one and a half seconds it
seems like a good amount - away
okay so we've just started streaming we
can see here that our request has been
received so we can see a speed on it is
processing it our server is streaming
back messages we're saying hello hello
Sydney
and now our server has finished and that
took 15 seconds because 10 messages
times 1 1/2 seconds we got 15 seconds
and that's so that's all there is really
to streaming I get so simple so you can
use that to have not just service
streaming you can have bi-directional
streaming so G RPC it's really great at
real-time services you can forget about
polling or having to like wait and have
someone call you you can just initiate a
G RPC call to the server and that
connection can just stay open
I mean as soon as the server has data it
can just push it down to you and you can
process it ok I've said a lot of great
things about G RPC why why aren't we
using it everywhere why don't we just
throw that Jason away it's awful I hate
it what about rest rest it's as old as
it's it's um apart so it's G ABC all the
things so well browsers have really good
hqb to support chances are if you've got
a browser open and you're browsing to
Google or Facebook or Stack Overflow or
all these different places you're
probably already using HTTP 2 the
problem is as browser API is they
haven't caught up so XML HTTP request
fetch they support 1.1 but they don't
support they don't provide access to
those low-level frames that we've added
an HTTP to and because of that some
possible to write a completely
compatible
gob C client and the browser so if there
is a workaround this sort of like a kind
of side by side specification called Qi
RPC web and it provides limited support
for calling shabby C services from the
browser
so this is just like a diagram of how
you can potentially use it there's a
lots of different ways of using Chi RPC
web where we can see on the Left we have
our browser and we've got an app which
is using to your PC web then that's
talking to a proxy that proxy will take
the GI PC requests and will then
transform them and call them as HTTP to
requests onto a G RPC server the GI PC
server can do stuff in a capacitor back
to a proxy and proxy can translate back
into G RPC web this works for the most
part there are some limitations with it
so you can't do client streaming you
can't do bi-directional streaming but
unary calls and service streaming calls
they both work you're probably thinking
I heard James I've followed your plan
we have blazing our blazer is dotnet and
the in the browser and dotnet supports
HTTP - unfortunately black blazer it
still lives and the like the browser
sandbox and it's only able to use those
api's that have 1.1 like if you're a
node you can talk full tree RPC but
within like the JavaScript browser
environment you're really limited to hqp
limited to G a B C - web currently our
implementation doesn't support HTTP web
like you use a proxy one of the things
we'll explore and the coming year is
like is it something that we should
implement properly if you've got
feedback on that please let me know and
it's not human readable so H GB - and
protobuf they're binary protocols you
can't read them both without tooling and
also you need to have the contract so
you need to have a contract to be able
to translate those numbers and to
property types and actually say what the
property type value is is a destroyer
assassin integer so you need additional
tools to debug calls so you can just
browse
or something and a browser like you can
with rest and get a response there are a
couple of tools I would recommend one is
bloom RPC so this is like an electron
app and using it you can load up a proto
file ad hoc you type in the address then
you can just start making calls if you
have familiar with WCF like there's a
WCF test client where you can point at a
proxy and start doing stuff and this is
kind of similar and if you really need
to go low low level and debug the
incoming requests in response
Wireshark is an option Wireshark isn't
easy to use it's a power tool I've used
it a lot but I think if you've got G RPC
services and they're working like
theoretically this isn't something you
should ever need to worry about because
the client and server will just take
care of it for you
so although Wireshark is a power tool it
does have some knowledge of G RPC so we
can see highlighted and read there it
recognizes that this request on this
line was a G RPC request and it's
provided some information to us about it
so you can see they're in quite small
text there's a headers frame there's a
data frame him it's another hitter's
frame so that indicates to us that this
is a G RPC response
I mean it's showing a bit of information
about the protobuf message and it's a
lot more useful than if you compare it
to a binary so the binary is down there
I'm a very bottom
that's the highlighted blue stuff really
it's a bunch of bunch of gibberish and
the only thing which really makes any
sense is there's some utf-8 ticks which
shows up as hello world so that's all I
have for you today
er PC is out on da near court today you
can use it there's a template with Shep
swift on air core 300 which I use that's
a good place to get started there's also
a great tutorial that tutorial will
cover both creating that service and
visual studio or vs code and then
creating the template there's a lot of
great documentation
on dr. Marek's Ofcom and there's a lot
on there which I haven't covered today
so gr BC and using it with orth
indication does it work the short answer
is yes it does logging in Diagnostics
how you how can you log what's happening
on your client and server we have
integration with HTTP client factory so
if you want to centrally configure your
client using di you can do that and then
then you can automatically inject it
into your services or any other place
who are using di we've also partnered
with some people in the community to
write a guide for migrating to WCF
migrating to GE PC for WCF developers
like how does G RPC compared with WCF
how they the same how are they different
what's missing from G IPC but you might
need to think about and that's also
available on dr. Marek's Ofcom and
that's it I think we've got about ten
minutes which has a lot of time for
questions if you have any questions just
raise your hand and let me know so I've
got one up the back there could you
speak up a bit so the question was about
how does G RBC work with services behind
load balancers so one of the issues
around G RBC is as a should be to only
and some load balancers and proxies
don't properly support HTTP to now if
your proxy properly supports HTTP 2 then
you're fine
GC will just work through it like any
other HTTP request if it doesn't support
HTTP 2 then you won't be able to use it
you'd have to either continue to use
rest or maybe use another technology
like G a B C - web yes
so the question was about using Google
protobuf and like Monsieur serialization
library
so although GRP see by default users
Google dot protobuf you don't have to
use it you can put in your own
serialization technology like you could
have G RPC sending and receiving Jason
so there's another protobuf library from
Marc Ravel and has arisen based on proto
files this is actually like code first
protobuf you can use that with the G RPC
server and client we've created just a
little a little bit more work and a
disadvantage as its not interoperable
with other languages like you've defined
your contract and a c-sharp class you
can't give that c-sharp class to someone
in Ruby and have them expect to be able
to call you like you can with that
protobuf file but yes the short answer
is it does work and like we we support
that but our official implementation as
protobuf files using Google dobro debuff
yes so the question was about versioning
and the contract so the contract you can
add new things to it like you can have a
service you can add new methods to it
that's fine if a caller calls a service
which doesn't implement their method the
service will just return not implemented
you can also add new fields to a message
so we could take our hello message and
we could have the name and then we could
add some additional metadata like we
want to say hello back to them and
shouty caps for example like if that
value wasn't set from the client it will
just come back as a null value like
it'll just come back as empty on the
server so yes you can version things and
like as long as you're not changing
what's already there like you can't if
you've already got a field and it's an
integer you can change it to a boolean
without changing both sides but
addition a few making additions and yes
versioning is fine yes yeah so I've wind
the is just like NBC where once the code
has finished executing the action slash
method and G RPC then the server
considers itself done and it just sends
a response back to the client to say yes
I'm done so a bad example I showed I I
probably should mention like I
simplified things a lot like those
frames can be more complicated like
there's other frames like there's a
frame about resetting a stream there's a
frame you can have frame metadata
metadata to say this is gonna be the
final frame of my stream there's other
ones about flow control so it's a bit
more complex than I showed but like I'm
a server yes like once your code has
finished and exits method it will just
automatically tell the client yes I'm
finished and that for each loop will
just stop because the service told it's
finished and it knows there's gonna be
normal messages yes so the question was
about geo PC streaming and reconnecting
er PC doesn't have any built-in
functionality around reconnecting there
would be something that you would need
to implement yourself there might be
something we might explore in the next
year for future additions to our library
around adding like more resilient
connections like automatic reconnection
but no like by default er PC doesn't
itself the specification doesn't know
anything about reconnecting but it's the
kind of thing you can add on yourself
potentially yes
can you use the new async and numerals
why I used one on the client so that's a
async enumerable so that's a for each
but rather than blocking each time you
say move next so we'll move next
asynchronously so like a few head I have
a server isn't reading anything the
server's the one writing like if you
were doing bi-directional streaming and
both the server and the client were both
right and they're both reading
simultaneously then yes you could use
Ayase and Canoe mirabile on the server
in that case yes so the question was
about using HTTP poly yes I believe you
might be able to so our client like I
haven't tried it and it hasn't occurred
to me until you've just mentioned it but
our client just uses HTTP client under
the covers so there's a potential that
yes that could work I don't know there'd
be something we'd need to explore yes
I do not know so you can like this
there's no like idea of wisdom there's
no like here is my publish contracts you
can go here and download them and then
automatically do things there's no spec
around that as far as I can tell an ERP
see I've been something kind of similar
like you can do some reflection and like
a server can provide information about
what end points it has if it doesn't
provide the protobuf file yeah like
you've got a bunch of options so you can
share it on disk like if you're both on
the same project you could have like a
central dotnet class library 2.0 it
could reference the proto file and then
you could do the compilation and code
generation on one package I mean you can
just reference that package from all
over the place you could then take their
package and you can put it on nougat and
then anyone can reference it if there
are some packages or we like that like
there's chappy C dot health checks
that's just some code generated and
proxies that have been been put on
nougat and everyone can reference so
there are a lot of options yes
you can pretty much use all the
authentication that's available that's
an asp.net core so one one that you
can't use as Windows authentication
windows authentication doesn't work an
HTTP - but like securing a GI PC service
shouldn't be much different from
securing a NBC controller like you can
just put an authorized attribute on it
and you put in the necessary middle wave
and necessary configuration and then
that middleware will just automatically
run women a request comes in if you get
a rejection like a it will return an
unauthorized response back to the client
and the client will say hey I can't do
this because I'm not authorized yes
behind behind you yes I don't know
anything about Asia functions so at the
moment Jia PC doesn't work
an azure app service we talked about the
issue with proxies before right now the
proxies that as you app service they
don't support the necessary features
they should be - that's something we're
working on so hopefully like no promises
but will aim for next year beginning of
next year to get Jia BC working on as
your app service so yeah I don't I don't
know anything about as your function
support they might like it's a good
technology and it's a good way yeah yeah
so as your functions runs on top of App
Service but beyond that I don't know
whether they might add like built-in
support for a gr BC endpoint for
invoking stuff so I'm Ferrand the what
handling
Oh server error handling so that PRP see
status let me just look how much time I
think this is the last question
so Jia PC the status which gets returned
you can also send back a description of
what error happened so you can give
information to say this was an
unauthorized response I mean you can
give some detail and that description
I guess not as rich as you might get
with some other technologies like WCF I
believe there are packages that you can
use to extend it there's something I
haven't looked at closely it no it'll
probably be something we'll look at
upcoming that's here ok that's it sorry
no more questions I'll be around all
conference so if you want to ask me just
come up to me and thank you very much
[Applause]